The IP addresses we've seen so
far in this course are specifically
IP version 4 four addresses.
There are two major versions of
the Internet protocol in use
today, v4 and v6.
v4 is the older one that the majority
of Internet traffic is using today.
We'll talk about v6 more
in the next lesson.
For now.
Just be aware that there are both of
these kinds of IP addresses out there.
And that they look pretty
different when we write them.
And there you're going to be
seeing these more and more.
Right now the ones we're
talking about are these.
The IPv4 addresses are usually
written as dotted quads.
That's four numbers separated by dots.
Each of these four numbers is
one byte or octet, or 8-bits,
which means that mathematically it
could be a value from 0 to 255.
Wait a minute, why 255?
Where did 255 come from?
If you already know the answer to that,
feel free to skip
the remainder of this lesson and
pick up again with lesson three.
But if you're not quite sure why 255 is
an interesting number, keep watching.